hey 42 here a duel can only take place
amongst two people if there are three
people involved it is actually called a
true
welcome to riff in 1990 a police
department in Michigan staged an entire
fake wedding with undercover cops acting
as the bride and groom they invited
numerous local drug dealers to the
wedding and busted them all at the
reception in 2006 an Australian man
tried to sell New Zealand on eBay the
starting price was 0.01 Australian
dollars but it managed to reach three
thousand dollars before eBay closed the
auction three brave Soviet engineers
volunteered their lives at Chernobyl to
release water from the broken reactor
had they not done this the nuclear
fallout would have covered most of
Europe all three men died shortly
afterwards the last time someone died
from a spider bite in Australia was in
1981 banana ketchup is popular in the
Philippines when the earth first formed
a day lasted for only five point five
hours at 5,800 degrees Celsius the
Earth's core is just as hot as the
surface of the Sun if you traveled at
the same speed that the earth travels
through space you could reach the moon
in 3.5 hours a spacesuit cost twelve
million dollars when you eat pineapple
it is actually eating you back it
contains an enzyme called bromelain that
digests proteins that's why your tongue
tingles whilst you eat it 25% of
Spongebob Squarepants viewers are adults
with no children the world's largest
tire manufacturer is Lego the toy
company produces 318 million Lego tires
per year a study in Sweden revealed that
women with breast implants are free
times more likely to commit suicide than
the average woman the air quality of
Mumbai is so bad that breathing Katyn is
the equivalent of smoking two-and-a-half
packs of cigarettes a day in the 16th
century women often wore a black face
mask whilst outside
called a visit it was meant to protect
the woman's face from sunburn the mask
was held on by a small bead inside the
mask which the woman will bite down on
to hold the mask in place thus making
her faceless and mute thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2